[Music]
welcome back to science clique today
geodesics and relativity
what is the distance between these two
points we could take a ruler place it on
the screen and read how many centimeters
separate point a from point b
we could also ask an ant to walk
straight from one point to the other and
count the number of steps it has to take
we measure the distance in centimeters
in the first case and in number of steps
in the second
but imagine now that points a and b are
on the surface of a sphere
what is the distance between them now
at first sight we could take the ruler
again and place it between points a and
b to measure how many centimeters
separate them
but if we ask the ant to walk from a to
b
since it remains on the surface of the
sphere it will follow a different path
from the straight line measured by the
ruler
the ant must walk a greater distance
because the sphere is curved it has to
cover a whole arc
it does not measure the same distance as
the ruler
our sphere is a two-dimensional surface
immersed within a three-dimensional
space
the ruler measures a distance through
space in three dimensions
we allow it to lie outside the surface
of the sphere
on the other hand the distance measured
by the ant is two dimensional
it is measured along the geometry of the
surface
[Music]
when we are interested in the intrinsic
geometry of a surface we don't focus on
the distance measured by the ruler but
on the distance an ant would travel
we measure this with a metric
a metric is a mathematical tool
which at any point gives us a grid
tangent to the object along which we can
measure length and angles
[Music]
to measure the length of the whole path
travelled by the ant we would add the
length of each of its steps
at each step the metric gives us a grid
within which we can measure the small
distance that the ant has just covered
by repeating this process for each step
we obtain the total length it has walked
[Music]
but what is the distance between a and b
by definition the distance between two
points is the length of the shortest
path that connects them
but at the moment we don't know if the
path followed by the ant is optimal it
might have walked in zigzags and taken a
longer path than the true distance
between the two points
the metric allows us to measure the
length of a path but it doesn't tell us
whether or not this path is the shortest
one possible
finding the true distance between a and
b
amounts to finding the most direct
trajectory that connects them
to do this we can imagine sending tens
or even hundreds of ants on the journey
each ant will try a different path
they all start from point a but some get
to point b quickly while others take
more time
thanks to the metric we can measure the
length of each path and by comparing
them find the ant which has travelled
the shortest path
if we imagine that we have tested the
infinity of possible routes we are now
able to determine the shortest path
the optimal path to get from a to b
this path determines the distance
between the two points
[Music]
this type of trajectory is called a
geodesic
is the generalization of a straight line
a trajectory along which one walks one
foot in front of the other
each step takes us forward along the
same direction as the previous step
we never stray off course
on the surface of a plane geodesics are
simply straight lines
that's why we can measure distances with
a ruler
when connecting two points visiting a
third point that is not aligned with the
other two will always require a longer
travel time
we call this the triangle inequality
on the surface of a sphere the geodesics
are known as great circles
they cover the greatest possible
circumference
on earth for example lines of longitude
are geodesics
a flight from rome to copenhagen will
only be as short as possible when
following this precise curve
on the other hand apart from the equator
lines of latitude are not geodesics
they are not great circles on the sphere
to connect two points at the same
latitude such as paris and quebec
there is a faster path
the field of differential geometry has
developed a whole variety of tools to
characterize the curvature of a surface
one of the most important tools is the
so-called curvature tensor
it is an object which expresses how
geodesics evolve
compared to each other
it measures the curvature of a geometry
because the more curvature there is the
faster the geodesics will converge or
diverge from each other
and conversely the flatter the surface
the more its geodesics tend to stay
parallel to each other
[Music]
when looking at more complex surfaces
geodesics can take interesting shapes
on the surface of this funnel for
example
straight lines seem to be deflected near
the central hole
when viewed from above these geodesics
appeared to bend in a manner very
similar to how light rays are lensed
near a black hole
and this is not a coincidence light rays
get bent for the same reason
the universe in which we live is not a
two-dimensional surface it is a hyper
surface with four dimensions
three dimensions of space and one of
time
this is space-time
all objects in the universe evolve
through space-time in the same way that
the ant walks on the sphere
but in space-time the distance between
two events is not only their distance
through space but also through
time when they don't experience any
force bodies in the universe have no
reason to turn one way or the other
objects have a tendency to move straight
ahead and they hence follow geodesics
they move along straight lines within
the geometry of the universe
our universe is very diverse and the
metric that describes its geometry can
vary from place to place
in an empty region of the universe
space-time is almost flat
the geodesics are the usual straight
lines and all objects or light rays move
straight ahead at a constant speed
we call this the minkowski metric
it is the type of space time described
by special relativity
any motion between two objects is
relative all positions and directions
are equivalent
however
close to a massive body space-time gets
bent
for bodies that are spherical isolated
unstable over time we consider the
schwarzschild metric
it is the most common metric in general
relativity
the geodesics correspond to deflected
trajectories or orbits
if the moon revolves around the earth it
is because it follows a straight line a
geodesic but within a curved geometry
somewhat like the funnel we saw before
the only difference is that this
geodesic is not only aligned through
space
it also describes the trajectory through
time
when an apple falls off a tree from a
previously motionless state it is
because the curvature of space-time
bends the geodesics between time and
space
the apple which was moving only through
time gets gradually deflected off course
its flow through time gets converted
into a speed through space
when the attracting body is extremely
massive like a static black hole the
schwarzschild metric describes a sort of
hull a spherical region of space much
like the hole in the funnel
the metric seems broken
this is called the schwarzschild radius
or more commonly the event horizon
as seen from outside no object can cross
this horizon
that said it is just an illusion
like the north pole on earth which
breaks apart when we flatten it on a map
an apparent singularity
in reality from the point of view of a
spacecraft approaching the black hole it
is possible to cross this region
unfortunately the spacecraft would end
up bumping into another singularity a
real one this time a point where the
curvature becomes infinite and that
modern science cannot yet understand
finally there exists a multitude of
other places in the universe with more
complex metrics
such as the kermetric which describes
black holes with a very fast rotation
with a central ring singularity
or the flrw metric which stands for
friedman lumet robertson walker which
describes an approximation of space-time
on a large scale
by expressing the curvature and the
expansion of the entire cosmos
it is at the origin of the big bang
theory
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you